a coders I'm Cody Seibert and welcome to
another tutorial where I'm going to show
you how to build a tree browser using
views j/s so basically on the right this
is what we're going to be building it's
a very simple component which if given a
tree like data structure it's going to
render out different divs that you can
expand and collapse to view the file
system or whatnot and we're using an
external module to kind of color the
files based on the file extension and
we're doing some cool little stuff
inside the component um and then lastly
if you click on one of these files it's
gonna invoke a callback where we simply
just display an alert but if you think
abstractly you could do whatever you
want such as render something over on
the right hand side maybe even show the
file contents after you click on one of
these files so this is what we're gonna
build let's just go ahead and start
building it so I went ahead and just
started up a project using the view CLI
version 3 so over here on the left you
can see the the bare-bones project is
ready to go one on the right we have it
running if we wanted to get started with
this component though let's go ahead and
create a new file called tree browser
dot view I'm going to go ahead and just
scaffold out a new view file here
and of course we need to go in the app
dot view and include that so let's go
ahead and just bring in tree browser
wherever we plan to use it
I'll get rid of this image here save
this file
this is working let's just go ahead and
display some text so I'm gonna say h1
hello and write that out full so at this
point we should be good to go to start
developing our tree browser component
the first thing I want to start with is
let's look at how some JSON data may be
represented to represent a tree
structure like a file system right and
we're going to define a JSON object and
pass that down into our tree browser as
a property so let's first inside our app
component let's define a data function
and let's return an object which has a
root object on top of that or it has a
root property
and inside this root property basically
a root is going to be a node which has
children so if you know much about like
graph theory or if you're done like
computer science data structures and
stuff we're basically just going to
represent a tree using nodes that have
children
so in this case our route is gonna have
a name so in this case we'll do a slash
and then our note it will have children
attached to it which is going to be an
array and then inside that array we can
have multiple other nodes so our first
note could be let's say music and then
of course that could have children keep
doing a capital M and then that child
node could be on our name of song mp3 or
something like that
so that's one folder that could exist in
our root directory if we wanted to make
another child we could do name and we
can say this is workspace that has
children and inside our workspace we
have multiple nodes and let's just say
we have one called source Jas
of what a file system looks like using
JavaScript objects again we have a node
which has a name and then inside that we
have children which has nodes and names
and knows the names etc etc and that
will go down to however deep your file
system is
so using that route data property let's
go ahead and try to pass that into tree
browser so the first thing I wanted to
do is I'm going to go into tree browser
I'm going to define a profs object and
again you could do a props array so I
could do props as array of node in this
case we're going to actually define some
defaults for props in the future so I'm
gonna do a props object which is going
to have node which is an object type
and once you define this props property
on your view component here you can use
it so for example in our app table view
I could simply just go over here I could
buy node to my root property in mice
inside my data function and now inside
of my tree browser I could simply do
node name to render out that first slash
that we had to find in our root
so hopefully that wasn't too confusing
we have a good understanding of what the
data structure is now we need to
understand how to traverse it to display
a file system so going back to our tree
browser the first thing we kind of want
to do is of course we're gonna have to
wrap this in a div because view requires
only one component which is exported in
your template so I'm gonna wrap that in
a div and just print out the name here
and I'm gonna go ahead and split this
out into two different sections so the
first section is going to be a div
called node
that's we're gonna have like the the
icons for if it was expanded or not and
the name of the node etc so I'll put go
ahead and put the h1 and that and then
of course down here what we're gonna do
is we're gonna call tree browser again
and I'll do this in one second fact I'll
just I'll just go ahead and do this now
so if we take a step back and look at
what we're trying to build it's a
component which recursively renders
itself multiple times so in order to
recursively call yourself we can just
say tree browser again
but we need to make sure that we define
a name over here on our component or
else you not you're not able to actually
recursively render yourself it won't
know what tree browser is let's take a
step back and think about what we need
to do so we already rendered out our
name node but remember we have this
children property which is an array that
we need to loop over
so inside view what we could do is just
at a v4 on side that tree browser
component and I'll save for node in no
dot children
I shall name the some child not note
of course if you're doing a v4 in view
you need to make sure you bind a key so
for now I'll just do child that name
um
and that is basically going to loop over
all the children of the node and create
a new tree browser object and render out
the name so the last step is we're
looping over all the children and
rendering a new treat browser component
but remember we require a node property
so over here I'm going to bind node
equal to the child I'll go ahead and
save that and notice here on the right
it renders out all of our nodes
one thing you notice is that the
indentation isn't really useful that we
can't tell like what is nested under
other things so I'm going to go back to
my style over here and just make it
scoped and this will make sure that all
the CSS inside the style is only scoped
to this component that we're looking at
and for a node I'm going to say
text-align:left and we're going to start
working on some logic to be able to
simply indent based on the level that
we're at so notice we have everything I
like to left how do you think we could
indent based on the depth right so if
we're at the root level we don't want to
add anything to the left but as we start
going down the depth of the recursive
calls we need to kind of indent
so what we could do is as a property
let's define yet another one called
depth that's going to be a type of
number and then we're going to default
that to zero for now
and basically as we call tree browser we
just want to
a depth of depth plus one
so if we're on this first entry we're
going to be depth of zero music will be
depth of one song will be depth of two
work space will be depth of one and
sources will be depth of two so now that
we have the depth in incrementing by one
every time we traverse down the
recursive call stack how do we actually
indent well we just have to use CSS
right and in view we could simply just
go over here and do a dynamic style
binding so I'll say bind style is equal
to an object and this is going to have a
margin left of
the depth times some amount and I'm just
going to go ahead and add pixel to it
you want to be proper let's just go
ahead and do string interpolation here
like so
so if I save this notice that now the
entries or nodes are indented correctly
based on the depth at where at
fact I think the text is a little bit
big so let me just make the font size
like 18 pixels instead and I'm going to
still seems kind of big let me look at
it Oh because we're using h1 so instead
of using h1 let's just go ahead and just
get rid of that for now and we'll fix it
up to make it a little bit better in the
future
okay so now we're making some progress
now we need to move on to kind of the
next step
which is the ability to expand and
collapse these different nodes depending
on if they're clicked or not so of
course let's go and add a new data
property to keep track of if we've
clicked the node and if it's expanded or
not so if I go with the data and return
expanded is false
we now have a property which is attached
to the root level of all these different
nodes and then we could just simply hide
or show the children based on if that's
true or not
so over here I'm going to say V if
expanded say that and notice that now we
only see this slash and again V if is
just a keyword in view where you can use
it to hide or show Dom elements based on
a boolean value
the next step is how do we actually see
or expand this view to see the children
what we could do for right now is just
add a click callback so say click and
then we want to simply set expanded is
equal to the opposite or negate of
expanded that's basically going to
toggle based on us clicking on stuff so
just to show if I were to click on this
now notice that it's toggling our
different things but unfortunately it's
hard to tell if something has been
expanded or not so let's go ahead and
add some icons to the node that we can
tell if it's been expanded or not so
let's add a span and I'm going to add
the class of type and basically I what I
want to do is just display either the
carrot to the downward position or care
to the right depending on where expand
it or not so in here I can do string
interpolation and say expanded question
mark and that's a ternary operator if
you're not familiar with you know
JavaScript ternary operators
so if expanded is true we simply want to
display the string are the symbol nine
six six zero
and then otherwise
we want to display
six five eight and six five eight
in the interpolation
well so now we have an actual icon which
changes based on if we've clicked it or
not
and now that we've done that we notice
that there's a bug right there's a
there's a the icon is being rendered
here four nodes that don't have any
children so let's try to prevent that
from happening so down here in our
component I'm gonna add a computed
object and inside here we can add a has
children property and that's just going
to return this Don node children so if
this is defined we have children if it's
not we don't have children
what we can do is only display this
stuff if we have children
so here I'm going to do a B if we have
children or has children
now when I say this I should be able to
go down and the icon is hidden if we
don't have any children the last thing I
want to do is I want to add a little
icon next to song for like just to kind
of further indicate that it's not a
folder it's more of a file so over here
I'm gonna add yet another span and I'm
gonna add a a symbol which is going to
be a circle here and I want to display
it if we don't have children so I'm
going to just do B else here but
basically now if we don't have any
children it's going to show this little
triangle icon so that's all : all but
how do we actually figure out if we've
interacted with clicking on one of these
songs so what we could do is we could
add a click call back here
to the node
and instead of doing expanded is equal
to 9 equals expanded I could say no to
clicked
of course past that the node
in fact I need to pass anything
and then down here we can add yet
another operative property called
methods
and that's going to have a method name
called note clicked which we're going to
do that same logic so this dot expanded
is equal to not expanded and let's save
and just test it out to make sure we
didn't break anything
but also what we want to do
want to check if the child has children
we want to go ahead and just omit a
event so that our app table you can kind
of do something depend on what you
clicked so over here I'm just going to
say if this dot has children
simply this dot Amit
on click now I'm going to send back the
node that was clicked though this dot
node actually in fact we don't we want
to do this when we don't have children
so only when we click files so sorry
about that just add a little negation
there and we don't we want to check if
we don't have children so this is
another cool thing that is attached to
view components the domani sign emit and
basically this is going to emit an event
called on click and it's going to pass
this as the data it's going to bubble
that up to any of the components that
are listening so inside at the view
which is our parent component which is
kind of listening we could simply just
do at on click and we could say I'll
call some random function so node was
clicked
course down here we could just say close
my data and I'll say this is gonna have
a methods property and inside the
methods we're going to say node was
clicked that's gonna take a node as a
parameter and we're gonna simply just do
alert no name just to print out the name
of what was clicked
and don't forget your comma there so at
this point let's go ahead test it out
and see if we're doing okay so we are
getting a little error called this as
children is not a function and because
computer properties are not actually
functions they're just bullying's or
they're just variables that you can use
so instead I'll just go ahead and
backspace those that function call I'll
save that and make sure there's no
errors in the console anymore so now
when I click song mp3
it should be saying this dynamite on
click and setting out the node
and then over here we're listening to it
and calling a node was clicked
but for some reason it's not actually
doing anything so let's go ahead and
just log out we are clicked and save it
here to see what's going on
so that's not being called so I'm
assuming that there's an issue here so
over here I can say also dot log we are
here
okay so we are indeed getting to this
point and we are emitting a on-click
event and the issue is is that remember
we're doing recursive calls so here if
we want to bubble that up all the way to
app time view we need to remember to
listen to the click call back here so I
can say at on click and I'm going to
simply just do emit
I'm gonna say on click
and then I could pass the note that was
clicked
think I need to do something like this
ode okay
so give it a callback function which is
going to take the note that was clicked
and just simply propagate it up and
there may be a different way to do this
in view if anyone has a suggestion as to
a better way to actually do this or I
just want to propagate propagate that
event up the tree and not worry about
having to declare an on-click and doing
that let me know but for now I think
this should work so let's go back and
try to expand and click on song and I
mean this cannot reverti emit of
undefined
is because we don't need to use this
here let me just go ahead and remove
that and see if we can actually get this
to work
there we go so sorry about that you got
a little debugging session then I mean
to UM take that long but as a recap well
it was wrong was we are recursively
creating these tree browsers so when we
click on song it's going to propagate up
to tree browser so we need to make sure
we're listening to that on click event
and just simply propagate it up until we
finally hit the parents on click
callback which is gonna be this
so again we'd add this because like
let's say you wanted to change some
other view depending on what the person
clicked and the tree browser component
shouldn't really be responsible for
knowing how to interact with that or I
mean a different way is you could
probably just pass in a callback
function here and call it when we click
on a node but I think this way is a
little bit more cleaner to actually emit
an event and then do something when it
happened
all right so now that we've made this
progress let's just go ahead and add a I
went ahead and just generated a JSON
object which has more realistic data so
inside our source folder I'm going to
add a route JSON file and I'm just gonna
go ahead and copy some jason that i
already created by traversing my
filesystem basically I just took like
one of my projects and it traversed the
node modules folder and all this other
stuff so if I save this we should have a
better example piece of data to play
around with
so going back to app W we could simply
import that so i'm say we're import
route from dot slash route json and
that's going to import that json object
then instead of using it here or instead
of defining this here I could just
simply delete what we got
and save that so now when we refresh the
page notice that we have a much much
larger file system example with a lot
more files so now I think most the
functionality is basically done we could
probably just spend a little bit more
time
changing up the styles and centering
this and stuff to make it look like I
did before so if I go back to app top
view let's just add a title here I'll
call this h1 tree browser or beautii
browser
go ahead and save that okay so let's see
if we can maybe style this a little bit
more so I'm gonna do body background
color I'm just gonna do a little bit of
a gray and then I'm gonna add color as
white now should be setting this to
white let me refresh
I think it's oh that's why
okay
now we actually have a little bit nicer
looking sample application so as a
little bonus what I'm going to do is I
want to import a function which is going
to take in a string and give us back a
color hash basically I can set different
string values depending on our different
color values depending on what the
extension is the JavaScript files may be
red JSON objects may be like blue or
something
so in order to do that let's go ahead
and go back to our terminal here I'll do
an NPM install and save there's a
package called color hash
which kind of gives us the opportunity
to do something like that and while
that's installing let's go back to tree
browser and let's simply import that
here so I could say import star as color
hash
from color hash
that we can say Const color hash is
equal to new color hash
kind of ignore what's going on over here
we're installing a note package so it's
going to keep on a refreshing until it's
done but what we want to do is basically
figure out the extension of the name
if we're at a node that has like you
know no children
and what we want to do is change the
style dynamically based on that Ash
so up here we're rendering out the name
here what I can do
simply wrap that in a span
and I'm going to say find that to style
and it's going to call a it style for
the node dot name I shall just do dot
node
and then down here we of course need to
define a method right so over here I'm
going to say
it's style and taking a node
need to do is we need to first take the
node if it has children so if no
children and we need to return some
style so I'm going to say return an
object it has color of some hexadecimal
so I'll just say like red for now
and let's see what this does if we were
to save this I'm gonna try reinstalling
my node modules I'm not sure what
happened but something might have broken
when I was doing my setup for this video
so let's just reinstall everything and
see what happens all right so now that
is redun reinstalling let's try to set
up our rerun our serve command and let's
refresh this page Oh
you notice here if we have children is
going to be red
so pretty much we can customize what we
want our folder colors to be
also one thing I've noticed is that the
icon is really really close to the name
so over here I'm going to just add a
margin right of 10 pixels to these icons
I don't know if I've actually added a
style called type so over here I'm going
to say Oh class a type yep and add a
class of type to this one too
so that looks a little bit cleaner
but back to what we're trying to do with
that new package we imported is
basically if we have children
some are coded red for folders and else
what we could do is we could simply call
this method so I'm gonna say return
color of color hash dot X and then I'm
going to get the extension of this file
which I can do node o dot name dot split
and then split it by the dot and just go
ahead and give me the right side and
this is probably not the safest way to
do this but it works for right now for
this little simple tutorial that I'm
giving
let's go ahead and save that and see if
this is working as expected
so now you'll notice that all my
different files depending on the
extension will have a different type of
color and it actually looked like it
worked for files that don't even have an
extension so cool that's working pretty
much exactly how we thought it was going
to work
and of course to kind of clean this up I
feel like I could dry this up a little
bit so here I'm just gonna say let's
tile is equal to red mm-hm instead I'll
say let color and then here what I'll
simply do I'll say if node dot children
or if they don't have any children I'm
going to say color is equal to at color
hash logic
and then down here I could just simply
return color
like so let's see if this works
go hard refresh just in case
so that is working as we thought it
would
so there you have it there's how you
build a tree browser using view GS and
really it wasn't too difficult
feel free to UM follow me on Twitter or
definitely subscribe to this channel if
you thought this was a good tutorial and
again I'm always open to feedbacks in
the comments of how I can make my videos
better and I'm also up and open to
suggestions as to what other type of
little modules or components I should
try to build in record and demo for you
all